[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous part of our discussion
uh i had emphasized
uh that this
this elasticity tensor written
in the void notation here we do not have
the c 1 2 bar equal to c 2 1 bar and
c 1 3 bar equal to c 1 3 1 bar
we don't have those kinds of things at
least
are not based on the minor symmetries
that we have in our hand till now
i've also had also mentioned near the
end of the lecture
that those things can be concluded such
symmetry can be concluded
only based on what is referred to as the
major symmetry and that is what we are
going to discuss
in this part of the lecture so
let me go to a new page
and start this topic of discussion
major symmetry
so this major symmetry arises
only if the stress tensor can be
written in this particular fashion
okay
now what is this u naught the u naught
is the strain energy density
now a little bit of
comment uh is in order here okay it is
the strain energy density
so as we are proceeding in this applied
elasticity course
we have not mentioned
or we have not referred or appealed to
any energy considerations
the reason that i have not done that is
because
uh is that i actually do that
i cover the energy considerations in
another course
called advanced mechanics of solids
which is
which is a mandatory course for the m
tech students
and which can also be taken by the dual
degree students as an elective
in the spring semester which is the next
semester okay
so an entire chapter with in-depth
coverage of all the energy
considerations is done here
and that is why i do not invest any time
in the applied elasticity course
on that uh nevertheless at least for the
sake of major symmetry
we'll we'll covered a little bit of this
but we are not going into
uh we are not going to get into a
discussion of of how and why this
particular relation can be written so
you have to accept this on
good faith as of now
so uh what we say next
is that uh if we can write this then
from this relation we can also write
that
del sigma i j
del epsilon kl is equal to
l square q naught
del epsilon kl del epsilon i j
now at this moment all this may seem a
little bit alien to you why are we doing
this
but you'll see in a moment okay there's
a reason behind this
and just like before uh we can use
different indices here so instead of the
iq we can write this as
sigma kl okay so if this is true
this must also be true okay that
del uh u naught del epsilon k l
and just like before uh from this
relation we can
differentiate this sigma k l in terms
with respect to epsilon i j
and obtain this relation
now uh what we must have
is that these uh this
this right hand side and this right hand
side you note
the only difference between them is in
the order in which the epsilon i j and
the epsilon k l are appearing
okay and you can
you can understand that
we must have
is equal to
again without uh without
a proper discussion of energy
considerations it may not be
that uh this kinds of arguments may not
be that much appealing to you
nevertheless i'll persist with it
that we must have this relations to be
true because
of the requirement that the
partial derivatives of the strain energy
density they must be continuous
okay i know this statement may not be
very appealing to you uh
but it is uh it is a true statement so
you have to accept that on good faith
right now that because the strain energy
density
must have continuous partial derivatives
so we must have this thing to be true
and if this is true
then this implies that del
sigma ij
del epsilon kl is equal to del
sigma l del epsilon ij
okay and because we have
we already have in our hand that
sigma i j is equal to c i j
k l epsilon k and we also have that
sigma
scale
is equal to sorry
l i j epsilon i j
so if you substitute this expression
here and we substitute this expression
here
then what we are going to obtain from
here is
simply that c i j
l is equal to k l
i j
because you can understand that uh
this expression will be derived with
respect to epsilon k
so that gets cancelled out and this is
this expression is derived
with respect to uh epsilon ig so that
gets cancelled out
so c i j k l uh it comes out to be equal
to
c k l i j now the key starting point
here
is this expression where we are
utilizing the
the expression or c the cij
in terms of the the strain energy
density
okay so because you're perhaps not
familiar with this kind of relation
that's why the whole argument may seem
not very appealing to you
but anyway so um
but the the important point to note is
that unlike
what we had at the in the at the end of
the previous lecture
that we could not say that c i j k l is
equal to c
k l i j that however we can say now
so the result of all of this is that
from the 36 independent constants
of the elasticity tensor that we had
earlier
okay so based on this kind of a major
symmetry okay so this is the major
symmetry
let me write that down this is the major
symmetry
so earlier we had the i j k l is equal
to c
j i k l and c i j
k l is equal to c i j l k but now we
have the
interchangeability between the first two
and the third four indices here as
demonstrated here
okay so based on this major symmetry
what we can say
is that if we go back to the previous
page that
c 1 to bar is indeed equal to c 2 1 bar
the 1 3 bar is indeed equal to c 3 1 bar
c 1 4 bar is equal to c 4 and bar and so
on and so forth
okay so all these 36 independent
constants that we had they are no longer
independent
so what we really have is
1 2 3 4
5 6 7
8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19
20 and 21 independent constants okay
so only so this since this and that
thing is going to be symmetric
we have 21 independent constants which
is a further reduction
from the 36 independent constants that
we had earlier
okay so that's what we are going to
write so based on this major symmetry
the 36 independent
components
of the
elasticity tensor
for the reduce
to 21 independent components
now uh further reductions
from these 21 independent comp
components
to fewer number of independent
components are possible based on
further symmetry arguments okay so
for example you can have orthotropic
materials transversely isotropic
materials
a host of them i'm not going to go into
a detailed discussion of that
rather what i will say is that the
highest amount of symmetry
okay if it can say something like that
the highest amount of symmetry that is
possible is for
the case when we have isotropin
okay so when we have isotropy isotropy
means
[Music]
it means that the material properties
are completely
direction independent okay so
for the material behavior
is the same in all directions that's
what is meant by
independent of direction
is the same in all directions under such
a
situation when we have isotropy
then these 21 independent components
they reduce to just two
independent components okay
so back in first year mechanics uh or
perhaps in your undergraduate days when
you studied
the the hooke's law or perhaps even the
generalized hooke's law
in terms of the young's modulus and the
poisson's ratio
so those are the two independent
components we are talking about here
so those materials were indeed linear
elastic and very importantly
isotropic which is why you had only two
independent components
so in the next part of our lecture we
are going into a discussion
of such kind of linear elastic isotropic
material behavior
but in a slightly more systematic
fashion compared to your
undergraduate days and we'll see what
the connection is with the fourth order
uh tensor cijk that we have been
discussing till now
all right with this i'll end this part
of the lecture thank you